anyone pass get some breaking news fda
announcing johnson and johnson's vaccine
is
safe and effective bringing it one step
closer to emergency use authorization
jnj saying and expect to deliver 20
million doses of the single shot vaccine
by the end of
march as other drug companies said to be
ramping up production
steve harrigan live in atlanta what else
are we hearing about the j j and the
other vaccine roll out there steve good
morning
good morning bill the vaccine rollout in
the u.s really depends on where you are
in the u.s some states doing
significantly better and faster than
other states
at the very top is alaska 21 of people
in alaska
have gotten at least one shot new mexico
next 20 percent
south dakota 18 connecticut at 17
at the very bottom of the list would be
georgia right here 11 percent
tennessee and utah also at 11 across the
us the average
16 percent of americans have gotten at
least one shot so far the governor of
connecticut ned lamont is saying
the federal guidance is simply so
complicated he's going to scrap it and
go by an age system
starting monday in connecticut if you're
55 or over you can get the shots
the governor says speed is the real
priority
these are our goals for vaccination one
get as many people vaccinated as quickly
as we can
especially those age-related who are
much more likely to suffer complications
and fatalities get the shots in the arm
as fast as you can
you mentioned the johnson johnson
vaccine expected out next week
that is a single shot vaccine 2 million
ready immediately 20 million
by the end of march and of course
moderna and pfizer both
ramping up as well 14.5 million doses
out to the states
this week that's up by a million and of
course the big question everyone wants
to know when will anyone in the u.s who
wants a vaccine be able to get it
right now the administration says that
is likely in july
bill thank you steve good news steve
harrigan in atlanta
it's great